是你的老粉丝，
然后今天跟男朋友一起来连麦的，
就是我们两个刚刚在一起，
然后但是他之前是分手的，
然后他这个分手的情况就是跟呃前任签了一个不太平等的这个约，
然后我让他跟你说吧，
好不好好哎，
龙飞姐你好，
说一下我的情况啊，
我大概是之前分手，
我们家的财产相当于买了一套房子，
但是这个房屋的整个的产权房产证是登记在前妻名下的，
这个整个生活主要是由我来出这个生活费，
然后前期也是没有工作，
他负责抚养孩子，
呃，
分手之后我们签了一个条约，
这个条约是呃，
我每个月给1万块钱，
给到我的前任作为整体的生活费跟抚养费，
整个的房子的房贷还是由我这边来还，
所以就相当于我房贷大概是在一万五左右，
相当于我每个月要出25000块钱，
但是呢，
我现在整个的工资一个月都不到25000块钱，
就完全没办法去负债，
我给他的一个就是签条约的那方面的一个财产，
现在由于我这一个经济问题，
所以导致这一两个月都没有按期把这个呃条约。
里面的款打给他，
所以就想请问一下这种情况我能不能再跟他重新协商一下关于我们财产分配的问题，
以及如果我一直没有足额打款给他，
或者是打一个我认为比较合适的一个款给他，
比如说只给他15000块钱这种样子，
呃，
在整个的这个法律上面会有有没有什么风险，
你和前妻之间是有一个小孩是不是对吧？
啊，
然后你们签的那个协议是去民政局备案的那份协议吗？
是的，
如果说是在民政局备案的协议，
他已经产生了法律的效力，
嗯，
你想要推翻这个协议，
有没有这种可能性存在呢？
有这种可能性存在，
那你这边的举证责任就非常的大，
我举一个例子啊，
说我跟我的妻子分手的时候，
我承诺说一个月给他1万块钱，
那个时候可能我的工资是2万块钱，
我能够承担得起，
可是突然疫情来了，
或者说突然发生什么意外了，
比如说我被裁员了，
我现在没有能力挣那2万块钱了，
我可不可以说重新调整这个数额，
这个在法律上是有这样的口子的，
再比如说我如果遭遇了重大疾病，
我自己已经没有赚钱的。
能力了，
或者说我遭遇了意外，
比如说我被车撞了，
或者是遭遇了其他什么意外的伤害，
导致我丧失了赚钱的能力，
我可不可以去重新协商，
这个数额在法律上是有这样的口子的，
那放到你的身上就是你得呃想尽一切办法去证明我现在的经济状况是不足以支撑这25000块钱的啊，
当初签的这个协议的，
你如果刚好，
如果刚好能支撑的，
他现在基本上每个月到手候也刚好就是两万五，
但他自己就是房租啊，
生活费就一点都剩不下，
如果说刚好够，
这种情况下也有一定的谈判空间吧，
也有一定的空间，
因为法律他不能强人所难，
法律他不能说让你遵守一个承诺，
导致你自己饿死了，
但如果是这样，
因为他跟我说，
就是他之后签了这份协议之后，
想跟前妻再去协商，
比如说一个月给一万五这种情况，
因为那个房子就就现在跟他也已经没有任何关系了，
他还会帮忙还一半的那个贷款吧，
就是他按照这个给的话，
前期不满意去起诉的话，
法院大概率会怎么判呢？
是说判照判按照前协议来执行，
还是说呃，
按照实际情况。
就是协商，
如果说现在前期去起诉，
要求给这个当初承诺的，
但是没有及时给到的这个钱，
这个是会得到法院的支持的，
但是说以后是不是按照这个标准给的话，
可能也要看双方的实际情况，
看你能否去证明你这边的收入确实是下降了，
确实没有能力承担这一部分了，
就是说已经发生的，
他如果去起诉的话，
法院会支持他还没发生的，
对吧，
还没到时间的那一部分，
是否按照原来的协议走的话，
他可能有一定的空间，
这个前期他自己是干什么工作的，
他的收入怎么样，
他能不能负担这个贷款，
他的经济条件可能也是一个重要的参考因素，
如果前期一个人带着孩子，
他要照顾孩子，
他又没有经济来源，
他也没有能力去承担这些东西的话，
那可能这个你们的心理预期要降低一点，
大概明白了，
就是说还是大概率按照协议来执行的概率比较大，
对吧？
是的是的，
当初呃，
你的这个男朋友，
他之所以选择给他1万块钱的抚养费，
之所选择承担1万五的这个房贷，
他一定是有原因的呀，
你也不知道下一。
就是我也没听说过这么高的，
我认为他当初肯定是急于逃离这段婚姻啊，
是的，
你说的对，
这个东西就是我们成年人要为自己的追求幸福也好，
逃离苦难也好，
离痛苦也好，
这就是我们成年人要付出的代价呀，
如果他比如说隔个5年8年再起诉的话，
那之前的每个月两万五是要给阿卡的，
就是接下来你有什么建议吗？
其实如果当初两个人分开的时候不是闹得特别僵的话，
其实可能坦诚的找到前妻，
告诉他我现在的收入确实是这样，
我不是说我不愿意去执行曾经对你的承诺，
是因为现在大环境的原因，
我自己工作能力的原因，
各方面的原因，
我确实是没有这个能力承担那么多一个比较那个有效的思路，
如果前期去打官司，
那么你的这个男朋友，
他面临的最坏的一个结果可能就是上了黑名单，
限制高消费，
这是他面临的最坏的结果，
做不了，
做不了高铁也也没有更坏的结果了，
这点可以了，
但是如果假设反过来讲，
我刚刚说的那个限制高消费，
这成成为最坏的结果，
他有一个前提条件，
就是说你男朋友他确实没有能力去支付这笔钱，
那么对于他来说最坏的结果就是限制高消费。
但是反过来讲，
如果他明明有能。
你确不去支付这笔钱的话，
那么对于你男朋友，
他还有一个更坏的结果，
叫拒不执行判决裁定罪，
谢谢龙谢行，
你太坏，
我们听故事的人啊，
咱们就是不要太代入听故事的人，
就是学知识，
听别人的故事，
最起码你听到这个故事的时候，
你学到什么知识点，
到了知识点就是如果要跟他分开，
签那份协议，
去民政局备案的那份协议的时候，
一定是要慎重的考虑自己的能力啊，
不是说我为了逃离一段婚姻，
就相当于说我我为了爬出这个泥潭，
我当时开一个天价，
我来爬出这个泥潭，
到最后发现这个开出的天价却成了你终生的一种负担，
不讲不过分啊，
不管是对男生还是女生来说，
我们都是成年人，
在逃离一段苦难的关系的时候，
也要去衡量逃离这段关系，
我所付出的代价是不是我能够承受的，
对吗？
姐妹们啊，
包括我直播间也有男同学同意吗？
就是你逃离一段段痛苦的关系，
你当时呃，
签的那个协议，
你要付出的代价，
你要对吧？
衡量一下这个是不是你能够承受得起的代价。